what's up guys it's adam here welcome
back to the iced coffee hour so far the
podcast has made a hundred and four
thousand dollars of revenue wow
well done
now this is really excited for for both
of us to have you on here we have never
met in person until like five minutes
ago crazy you are the founder and ceo of
yatta bank i like the way you said that
very good thank you i like it the uh 10
million dollar bank
that i bought that's right a year ago
could you believe it crazy crazy a year
yes it's crazy i haven't met you i've
met a lot of people over the past year
yeah so it's nice to finally do that for
sure well thank you so much for coming
all the way to las vegas we have a lot
to address today uh because you run a
bank that i invested in that pays people
up to 10 million dollars now i want i
want to mention this this video is not
sponsored you're not paying us to be on
here so we're all good we just want to
have an honest conversation and address
all the rumors about this being a ponzi
scheme interesting when i posted my
video so many people got upset they
unsubscribed from me they said i was
promoting a ponzi scheme so no matter
what i say they don't believe me so we
have to have you on so we could confront
you
and uh get to the bottom of it yes yes
i'm happy to happy to alleviate any
concerns answer any questions so
yeah where should i start what's i want
to start from the very beginning so you
grew up in l.a didn't we have a few
mutual friends this is how we started
talking so tell us about like where you
grew up how you got involved because
your whole family is in the finance
industry right pretty much yeah so i
grew up in in la uh went to college at
penn wharton so i went to business
school pretty much everyone in my family
went to wharton which is pretty nuts uh
studied finance and accounting uh
parents in finance pretty much every
family's in finance in some way which is
also strange um what does it mean by in
finance you know whether it's investment
banking investing hedge funds real
estate you know lots of different areas
um your specific role in that uh like
sector was to find businesses that were
in distress that could potentially be a
good investment
basically so i was an analyst which is
the very junior junior level there so i
was only there for a year and so you
work with a vice president who's
probably got seven to ten years of
experience oftentimes they're doing the
work of trying to identify the
opportunities and then the analyst works
with them to evaluate the opportunities
so a lot of excel work and modeling at
the company meaning
put in all their historical revenue all
their financial data they report
publicly make projections
based on those projections have
different assumptions based on if they
grow at this rate or this rate what does
that mean for their future so
my job there was more of like the
analysis helping
my vp that i worked with evaluate the
opportunity
um at the at the junior level you're not
you can like identify opportunities but
it's more typical because you're just
starting out to work with someone who's
doing that and then
work with them on evaluating it okay
what level of your work was like
subjectivity versus objectivity when
like appraising or valuing a
yeah
um
i would say a lot of it maybe
in my role like in the analyst level
yeah
my role is probably more on the
objectivity side just strictly numbers
yeah historical data compiling
historical data um
manipulating it in such a way that made
it
easier for us to understand
um
and yeah i would say and then the
ultimate decision was made by people
higher up should we make this investment
or not
you're not making that many investments
per year so you know you you spend most
of your time passing on on opportunities
so would this be like me telling jack
like hey i want to i want to invest in
real estate in summerlin go and look
through all these 50 properties bring me
back the five that you think are the
best investments something like that and
then i'll review those sort of i mean at
my level it was more like here are what
i think might be the best five help us
help me figure it out um and at the at
the higher level it was identifying
those five within the 50. got it okay
what were your hours and how much how
much does that pay as an intern yeah so
the hours in my group which by the way
are actually much better than investment
banking in a lot of finance hours it's
probably 8 30 to 5 a.m to 10 30 p.m or
11 p.m whoa
i know whoa wait this is right out of
college yes yeah so and again that's
much better that people are jealous of
that
but how how does that not break labor
laws because you're not like an
independent contractor you're like
actually a salary to people i think yeah
yeah salary you could just say whatever
hours you want right
right
i think so yeah i think i think when
it's hourly then you start getting into
the overtime double time you know right
i think salary is just
if you work more right am i am i wrong i
think so i mean yeah i think so i mean
if you're an investment banking at
goldman you were working
you get in later like a lot maybe 10 11
am but you're working until 2 3 a.m a
lot of days
um
why so late why do they start late
so if you're if you're a junior analyst
the lowest level investment banking a
lot of your work will come in in chunks
so
everything in this in the finance world
for whatever reason investment banking
you're working for a client and so
you're trying to do your best for a
client which often means everything
needs to get done as soon as possible or
yesterday because you're trying to just
serve them the best way even if they're
not going to look at it for two weeks if
you do it as soon as possible they're
gonna
they're gonna like working with you
and so when work comes in it's the
analyst's job to do this as soon as
possible
and that's really what happens and so if
you
get work at 2 p.m and it takes you till
2 am to finish because your job is to
finish it as soon as possible you wake
up the next morning
there might not be anything to do until
3 a.m so there's there's like down time
yeah where you don't have anything to do
and then there's there's just you either
don't have anything to do or you have
stuff to do that you should have
finished
yesterday so that 14 hour schedule the 8
30 to 10 30 is a worst case scenario
no i would say it's maybe a best a best
case scenario
well for my group because again we're on
the investing side so we were investing
goldman's money we weren't working for
an outside client which means things in
our group weren't always
needs to be done as soon as possible
because we didn't have a client that was
hiring us you were moving around
goldman's yes
where do you put goldman's money i mean
why so why doesn't goldman just say hey
we watched graham's video he says just
buy the s p 500.
why
why do we need you adam why don't we
fire everybody we're going to save a lot
of money and we're just going to index
funds why why do they need to do all of
this can you explain that yeah well you
know they're making fees off well not
their own money but oftentimes they
raise outside capital basically they
believe they can get risk-adjusted
returns that are higher than what an
index fund might pay
whether they can or not
you know that's again that's an academic
question there's a lot of evidence that
shows you know
active management
neta fees doesn't outperform but some do
and look if you take more risk over the
long run
you might outperform but it's probably
because you're taking more risk yeah you
know what there's a i'm gonna
estimate this study i remember reading
it quite a while ago um
something it was something like 33 or it
was like 35 percent of actively managed
funds in the short term outperformed uh
the s p 500 but i think it was over uh
it was over a 10 or 20 year stretch
that
whittled down to like one percent in the
short term i think a few of them were
able to consistently beat the s p 500 up
to like a five year term uh but i think
the point that you mentioned was risk
adjusted right how much risk do you want
to take versus how much money do you
want to make and i think with a lot of
these people they don't want to take a
lot of risk and you're okay earning a
little bit less just for a safer
investment so is that what you were
trying to find these safe investments
yeah so
it would depend there's also an element
here which there's some investments that
are that are open to
um you know it wasn't all public stocks
so retail investors it's hard to invest
in a company in bankruptcy um it's a
complicated situation and so we would
also go into those types of situations
where their opportunities aren't even
accessible for the most part to like
retail investors which means
non-institutions
and so
you know there is some argument if you
can get into some of those opportunities
that you know the average person can't
then
there might be opportunity there because
there's not as much focus on it there's
not as much information that's that's
publicly available and so you might have
less competition for it if you find if
you source that deal that no one else is
looking at
um
i forget your original question was
though how much do you make how much
that returns or no no no like how much
was your salary oh right so i think
starting out this was seven years ago
now yeah the base might have been like
75k and you could expect a bonus
similar to that i would say maybe
50 50 50. it's about
a year
seven years ago now
i think the starting salary for a lot of
like investment banking roles might be
like 110 120.
yeah
because they're competing with well
i mean they're competing with tech now i
mean tech's much more appealing to a lot
of hungry
smart young people and so
you know you can go work at google make
if you're an engineer make 12 120 130 k
out of school maybe
and work not work 8 am to 3 a.m you know
um
work
10 a.m to 5 p.m
right right
what was your schedule like for that one
year
did you just do nothing but
work i mean was there any day off or is
this like seven days a week do you have
time to watch tv
do anything a little bit yeah i mean
yeah yeah you get you get home at like
10 30 11 probably most nights okay um
watch sportscenter maybe five days a
week though yeah i mean you'd have work
on weekends too mine wasn't as bad on
weekends yeah they actually have
instituted might they might have had it
back then the saturday rule they had to
institute have you guys heard of this
yeah where they have to give one like i
have to give the saturday offer oh no
what is it like a half day right
different for different different for
different companies but some of them
were like you're not allowed to work on
saturdays which you know in effect if
the workload's the same just meant like
the rest of your week's crazier so it's
like this protected saturday rule which
my group didn't have which i actually
liked better because
i'm a big nfl fan so i wanted to get my
work done for for sunday so i could
watch football all day right so i would
have rather protected sundays and then
do the work saturdays but yo yo but
first i want to thank our sponsor ladder
alex what did i tell you man no hat
we want to talk about some things that
have revolutionized the way that we live
in modern society these things are known
as disruptors these are things such as
wireless headphones smartphones and even
self-driving cars well what about
all-in-one body wash shampoo and
conditioner no alex for the last time no
one likes those well
what about ladder
for once alex you're right ladder took
the life insurance industry and
basically flipped it upside down and
then shook out all the inefficiencies
before ladder if you wanted life
insurance you'd have to drive all the
way to the other side of town forget
about it with ladder they made it easy
for you to get term coverage on your
time and it's a hundred percent digital
when you apply for three million dollars
or less in coverage no doctors no
needles no paperwork so if you're
between the ages of 20 and 60 like alex
and i and you want to work with the best
company redeeming the whole life
insurance industry choose ladder so go
to ladderlife.com
iced coffee today to see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder
slash iced l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
ladderlife.com
iced coffee thank you so much ladder for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
it's interesting because 14 hours a day
is basically if i'm doing my outright
it's like 70 hours a week right so
effectively wouldn't you basically be
just working extra hours and in return
being paid the same wage as like a i
don't know a person making 60 000 a year
but you're just working on an hourly
basis yeah yeah probably but you do the
math but you don't do it for the money
you do it to get your foot in the door
so that one day yeah yeah sure how much
are the top level guys making well
that's the thing right you set yourself
up for
working in you know a big a bank like
goldman or in the finance world
is one of the if you can get in and do a
good job i'd say it's one of the less
risky ways to make a lot of money in
life as long as you do well and you
climb the ranks like if you're a
managing director at goldman again back
then you might have managing director
sorry i don't know if you want you can
do the explanation but it's one of the
more senior okay senior roles probably
so they direct they manage the people
underneath them like like they manage a
whole bunch of use yes okay it goes
typically analyst the bottom associate
vice president managing director partner
senior partner got it okay so if you're
a managing director you might be 34 35
years old
and your base
i don't want to get this wrong but it
might be today 500 000 plus a hefty
bonus that might be depending what
department you are
equal to that sure so you can make like
a million bucks a year yeah 12 years out
of school if you if you rise the rank
some people make a lot more than that if
you have a really good
year whatever that means for your role
and so yeah even though at the beginning
it's um
tough and
a lot of hours there's two things one
that the trajectory is possibly very
lucrative second is you're learning a
lot i mean you're putting in a lot of a
lot of time and so if you're putting in
twice as many hours as someone else in
different fields or in your field
you know compounding effect like
compound interest there's compound
learning
um on your time right so
yeah now i saw one of these vice videos
then take this with a grain of salt but
one of these vice videos was an
investment bank and they're like the
parties are crazy all the stories you
hear about are true
it's all of these uh illegal stuff and
like how is that true you don't have to
tell us parties
yeah so you know we just met i don't
think i've been to a party i'm not a
party person yeah so i don't know i've
been to
i went to maybe two two parties my four
years of college maybe maybe three sure
uh
so it could be true i i was never there
what what what did you hear they said it
was like the wolf of wall street sort of
that's what they were saying it's you
know vice they do these videos where
it's just like they like to like screen
dramatize everything or whatever sure
but it's fun to believe that's true
i don't know i mean it's like in between
meetings they're just like doing stuff
and they hire people
either i wasn't invited i wasn't invited
to them maybe but or i chose not to go i
don't know but yeah i've heard stories
that it used to be in the 80s and 90s
like definitely the wolf of wall street
culture was sure somewhat real i think
that's probably less so now but i don't
know i i never observed any of that
but what about the substance of like
usage is that still substance abuse um
again i i'm so the wrong person for this
i i've i've i mean how do you think they
stay up that many hours that's what that
is that's a good question yeah i've
heard i've heard i've never seen things
but yeah i've heard adderall things like
that yeah yeah there's actually an hbo
show that's that's good that's in the
life of uh
investment banker type junior thing
where i watch a couple episodes but they
have that element in it yeah i wonder if
it's like for me when i see those real
estate agent shows i look at that as a
former agent i'm like oh yeah that's so
unrealistic i'm wondering if investment
banking is you see you see these things
with these wild parties like that's
impossible they wouldn't be able to wake
up the next day and like get their work
done
yeah i mean
i've heard again i haven't seen anything
but i i think it
the adderall type stuff is
probably real yeah
uh what else i i don't know sure you
know what's interesting to me is that
the s p 500 is still it's human decided
they still pick out those 500 stocks so
why is that just like the the temple to
every investor like why can't someone
else do something that the s p did but
better because before the s p there were
other things doing the same thing and
then the s p came and then they did it
better
so why can't someone else do yeah so i i
don't know if i have a great answer or
that great insight here i mean a lot of
people used to use the dow right as like
the holy metric but it's just like 30
companies correct which isn't that
representative of of the economy as a
whole which is kind of what i guess the
s p is trying to do right it's 500 of
the biggest companies yes i don't even
know how they were picked i don't even
know they were hand picked yeah there's
there's a criteria there's like five
different uh things that they have to
comply with before they're even
considered and then a team votes on i
think it's seven people
interesting yeah test did tesla just
make it in really yeah yeah it's there
huge now but
yeah so i don't i don't know i think the
s p is also an interesting proxy for
society because i think now it might you
probably know this better than me but it
might skew very
tech heavy and so
pandemic happens right we have the
markets crater for a month since then
we've whatever doubled since march of
2020 but like that doesn't necessarily
mean the economy's i mean the economy is
probably doing well by a lot of measures
but there's a lot of winners and losers
in society right so for a lot of the
pandemic the tech
the rich got richer the tech companies
got bigger and so the s p was going up
investors who were invested in the
markets were doing well but the people
invested in the markets are usually
people who
have money right or have more money so
you know we think of the s p as a metric
for the economy but again i'm just
guessing we don't like the numbers but
it's probably skews more towards like
tech oh absolutely so yeah i think the
top five companies make up 25
somewhere around there the s p 500 right
yeah so it doesn't doesn't tell you
anything about the mom and pops and and
restaurants and
right all those types of
right right so when you finished up your
year
at uh goldman sachs you decided that
wasn't for you you didn't see a career
path of working your way up the ranks
yeah so i'd say about nine months in i
realized i had made a career choice and
again i liked finance a lot that's why
i'm doing what i'm doing now in a lot of
ways but
i interned in my summers at college in
different finance jobs i never really
liked it i just kept doing it everyone
around me was doing it everyone at
warden kind of gets caught up in the
same path at least 10 years ago seven
years ago
consulting finance and so i never really
thought about what i wanted to do again
everyone in my family was in it was in
this industry and so
i kind of realized i got there kind of
on autopilot in a lot of ways
and so i woke up one day and just
decided started thinking about what what
do i really what am i really interested
in what i really enjoy doing um and this
is about nine months in and i ended up
leaving a little about a year in yeah um
and started thinking back to in high
school i really liked programming i
never pursued it i like the idea of
learning about all these companies in my
job but i wanted to like be the person
on the other side who was trying to do
the strategic side of how do we grow how
do we make more revenue and all this
kind of stuff yeah
and so i realized i just got there by
default
what did your parents think nine months
in we were like mom dad i'm leaving
goldman sachs can do my own thing
they were supportive at the time i
didn't leave to like start a
company at the time right and so it
wasn't like i was going to do
become a youtuber right which uh you
hear stories about that which is uh so
so like
yeah it was it was it wasn't it was
supportive i mean
what about the finances because you're
you're leaving a full-time job to do
something that potentially makes no
money right right well at the time so i
left goldman and i did a coding bootcamp
because i knew i wanted to possibly
start something someday and the way the
world was going i decided that knowing
how to code i didn't want to be an
engineer but i wanted to like know how
to code so that i could understand how
how are things built that would help me
be a better
manager i guess or just know what how
long is something gonna take is it
possible
um and so i only was without income
probably for three or four months and
had savings at the time and then and
then right out of that coding bootcamp
which i'm very happy i did i got a job
at a tech company how much were you
making there 100 100 000 at the
beginning
wow what were your hours there
i would say on average nine to six
thirty like wow yeah that's incredible
so your wage effectively is also
significantly higher
yeah well with uh the bonus may have
made the finance wage higher sure uh but
yeah i guess the base the base was
higher but that's interesting it took
you four months to make 100k per year
but it took you four years
to make you know
100 whatever again i think in finance
right if you stick with it the
in tech you start out at a number and it
doesn't necessarily go up by that much
over time i mean it does and finance
like you start out with a number and
then ten years later you're making a
million million
would your parents have uh been
improving had you decided hey i just
wanna do music i wanna play you know the
cello and just do my own thing if it
might not make any money but i think
they would have been supportive but i
think they would have said adam you're
terrible at art
i mean yeah i can't i taught myself the
pianos not not great yeah i was never
good at uh it was held back in preschool
because i couldn't you know finger paint
that's not i was held back in preschool
but
i couldn't finger paint that's not why
yeah um
so they would have been supportive yeah
okay if it was something that was
bizarrely out of character like music
i think it would have been like well
you're gonna
make any sense but yeah
uh
yeah yeah okay
got it and what about like throughout
college and everything were they were
they helping you like like financially
through all of this or like
yeah yeah through college for sure yeah
um and then yeah early days new york for
sure too yeah got it that really i think
helps a lot because that that takes
almost the pressure off of like
needing to make those rent payments and
the food payments instead putting all of
your emphasis and time on like honing
the craft the finance oh definitely it
also makes it a lot easier to
if you're if you're fortunate enough to
be in a position where you have
a help or a backstop where you're not
taking a total risk and if you fail
you're going to be on the streets yeah
it's definitely a position i was lucky
to be in yeah um because you know again
if i
started a company or whatever i did
early on and it just failed and you're
not making much money
then for a lot of people it's like a
risk that
you can't take yeah even if you really
want to
when do you decide to do yada bank
who came up with the idea was it you you
have a co-founder ben
so ben joined a few months after i
started working on it um so originally
it was just me so so the story there was
i was at that tech job that i joined for
about three years
and i had the itch to to do something on
my own and so over the years i'd written
down
ideas um on a google doc
ideas that i saw or opportunities or
problems i ran into in the world what is
the idea i want to hear some of these
ideas by the way okay yeah we can we can
get to that now or let's hear it now
let's hear it now because we're going to
tell a story here i want to hear this
okay i mean there's there's a lot of
them yeah i'm trying to think of the
best ones or the worst ones or maybe
best okay so
one idea i was i was super excited about
and i didn't think about this as like a
business possibly but
people are late all the time you have
group dinners things like that
everyone's always late
and so i wanted an app where you could
create an event like whatever it could
link to your google calendar and you
could charge people for being late
so i would love that oh my god
i would love that i would too
so so you could say okay i'm gonna we're
gonna have dinner 7 30 saturday night
midtown manhattan right someone needs to
do this and you set you set a dollar per
minute that's like the penalty you set
whatever the penalty you want
and then like 30 minutes before the
event
gps's turn on for everybody you can see
them on the map and it shows your eta
and your expected payments like maybe
someone's expected to be five minutes
late so it shows like five dollars right
now maybe they get there early and so it
reverses
but um
yeah so like that would cause a lot of
accidents
yeah maybe someone's like on their last
dollar a minute yeah yeah this red light
is gonna cost me yeah
a minute yeah you'd see some crazy
stuff out there
i still want it to exist
they wanted to exist too i would use
that would you but yeah i don't think
you would sign up great employers are
you that for their employees are you are
you late are you you're graham is late
graham's late i don't act like i always
think that i'm i'm always very prompt
but certain things it's like if it's not
urgent if there's something urgent i'm
right on time if it's like going to the
gym and it doesn't matter if ten minutes
either way
you know
he's late yeah like it's time we would
play you know beach volleyball in
manhattan with friends and like you'd
have the court for an hour right and if
people weren't there on time like you
just can't play you know what i mean
like you don't have players so we'd be
waiting there for like 15 15 20 minutes
a third of our time and i just get so
frustrated by it and i think it stems i
don't know if this happened 20 years ago
because 23 years ago before cell phones
if you were late like you're just
screwed yeah right you can't say hey i'm
running late yeah right but cell phones
i guess sorry like i'm i'm 10 minutes
late
and so a lot of people say like oh yeah
i'm on my way no they're not on their
way they're in the shower
yeah i would love that app
seriously i think i think for employers
and employees that too imagine that
imagine just incentivizing your employee
like hey just download this app if
you're on if for every minute you're
early what employee would sign up for
that i don't know think about how much
time is wasted waiting for people oh
yeah i mean it would save
we need to internalize these costs you
know like we need to and you know what
it would be good for free friends and
stuff you created the app you just
charge it through you just siphon off
yeah you charge a little three
so it just transfers the money from the
person who is late to the person news i
developed i made a prototype for this
can we not it was called it was called
punctual can you
do this is just like like a gag sort of
thing get it developed get it up and
running it's just so much funny
that's word of mouth because i guarantee
one person is going to tell another it's
gonna be like bro i made 15 bucks the
other day it's like just so crazy that
it might work it sounds like you're
really for you concept the issue was i
had i had the assumption that like late
people they want to be on time and like
they just have a tough time like doing
it yeah and so maybe some like incentive
that they could put on themselves but
they don't want to be on time that's the
problem yeah like they don't you don't
know you haven't launched it yet i had a
prototype i tested with some friends the
late people they were still late and we
didn't have all the bells and whistles
where it like forced payment right so
you
forced people yeah if you just think
about it
so it's if you're late you don't want to
be able to have like venmo the person it
has to be into a crash
that sucks for you i guess yeah you
can't control what people do no
there's going to be like right you could
charge an escalation you know take a
picture of the accident
so many fights i feel like between
friend groups and i feel like it would
be inappropriate to use employers
imagine between husband and wife what
that would do oh my boyfriend girlfriend
girlfriend's late boyfriend's late
something like that yeah then money gets
saved she's like give the money back
it's like don't i can't reverse it
i love the idea oh but that's hilarious
here's the one part where i do think it
uh you would have to make sure it's it's
it's correct doesn't glitch is if you
arrive
and somehow it it keeps tracking you as
being late
yeah or they're like i showed up on time
but the app didn't update i was an error
in an area without reception so you
could have your verification system
where the event host can like confirm
yeah but one of the event host is on
that yeah then it was just like oh i
forgot yeah you know we we can figure
this out i think we can figure it out i
like that i love it i love if there's a
true way to get that done
where it's not glitchy
i love it so there's a lot more i like
that idea a lot that to me is an eight
out of eight and a half out of ten all
right i don't know if it would be like
number one in the app store
for people like us three i think it
makes sense but for people that are a
little bit more like like like if i had
a few of my friends i know for a fact
none of them would sign up for that for
someone like me i think it's funny and
i'm like oh it's a couple bucks here and
i like being punctual you know but for
my friends they're like why would i sign
up it does only benefit the person who's
hosting here yeah so
we had a pro i had a prototype for this
but i outsourced the development very
cheaply yeah because i was just funding
it it just for fun and it was super
glitchy but i found myself again i'm
pretty introverted i don't go out much i
was creating events with friends just to
get them on and try it out
um
i like that a lot that's something i
would do you could make a video i just
bought a uh a
late app that yeah it could be the title
if we could maybe we maybe we talked
about actually doing this seriously
maybe we talked about actually doing
this yeah i think listen i i think if it
costs under 10k to like get a prototype
out there
i could just do a swipe up like guys
just try this out
i'm down i'm down we could build it
better than i did yeah three years ago
okay another idea that came to mind
again there's a lot and my memories a
little bit
um was helping people save money on
their property taxes and we're going to
start with i think illinois and texas
where property taxes i believe are
higher again
something yeah but a lot of people if
you just fight your appraised value and
you might know about this from the real
estate world but you can like submit
documents to the to the county whatever
and say hey there's evidence that my
property is worth less than
what you guys are assessing the taxes at
and automating that so this was a big
issue in california it's something i'm
very familiar with um the
county assessor actually sent out a uh a
psa to all property owners they mailed
it and they sent an email um usually in
a given year they would receive a few
thou this is just the county valley a
few thousand requests a year and they
could handle it uh those services have
gotten so popular and and we're just
talking like the template format where
you could go and pay some guy 300 bucks
who's going to try to negotiate your
property taxes down and they just send a
template now they got almost a hundred
thousand
from like a few thousand dollars how
recently was this uh last year
yeah so it went from nothing to a
hundred thousand the service popularized
uh the assessor basically said at this
point we're understaffed it's going to
take us
years to go through what we get in like
a month
so we simply can't do it anymore so they
basically just said we can't handle it
anymore it's actually backing up the
legitimate claims
and because of that because we're
understaffed we're just not going to do
this for anybody so they were basically
just pleading to people hey if this is
if you have a real reason to believe
your property tax is good please submit
something but if it's just a template
thing from a lawyer um it's just it's a
backstop please don't do it it was just
a please they can't stop so so that's
something
uh yeah i i'd give that a two out of ten
okay fair two out of ten on that one and
you're all yeah that's it's tough
because you're exposing if they change
if whenever you do these hacky like save
money legal things you're always they
could change yes the rules yeah so i
don't like that one but what that's fair
i like it i like the honesty yeah
perfect so i do just want to say that
reminds me a lot of this idea i had and
i almost put this into action and i had
a business partner for it but to go to
the unclaimed funds thing oh i had that
same idea and then because it was clean
funds thing uh so the state of
california basically like if you if you
pay too much in taxes or something you
change addresses all these things like
uh they can they basically owe you money
and there's a log of it all online and
you can see their name you can see their
address and you can see how much money
that they owe you or for example like
transfer of estate something like
someone dies and they have all this
money and they don't know who to give it
to you uh or they don't know where you
went and you were in that will and
you're in the will they basically have a
log of all that and i had the idea of
going to those people's addresses and
saying hey the state owes you you know
five thousand dollars uh you were
completely unaware of this it shows that
it's been owed to you for five years uh
you know it would be nice if you could
charge me a finder's fee just for this
however i wouldn't make it mandatory
because it's their money in the first
place so two things first of all that
does exist uh it's called unclaimed
property and anyone could do it in all
50 states just type in unclaimed
property your state you'll type in your
first and last name and you'll go
through and you'll be able to see what
uh what they owe you it's legit um so
i've gone on before and i think it was
like a phone bill something or other
and uh i was at like 50 bucks so
i'll tell you the two downsides of that
one that exists and there are companies
out there that do this is a full-time
thing they just find people with with
high amounts above like 500 bucks and
they reach out to those people saying
you have money owed
the problem with that is that first of
all the paperwork is terrible i went
through it
you have to sign this thing you have to
get it notarized you have to mail it in
it takes like six to 12 weeks to get
back and then they send you a it's like
for small amounts like 10 15 it's
probably not worth it could you do it
better where you automate a lot of that
stuff or the problem is you need a power
of attorney so the issue that that i've
seen with a lot of these companies is
that nobody trusts them
and i actually had this one guy reach
out to me and i was so skeptical and he
was an older guy and just called me on
my my cell phone like i didn't really
give it out but he called me myself and
he says hey um you have unclaimed
property that's like 700
and wouldn't tell me where it was or
like how to find it he's like it's not
it doesn't show up in the database yet
uh but we want to give you the we're
gonna handle it but we're gonna take 20
percent of that so if you want to claim
this we'll do all the work for you we
just need you to send over a power of
attorney to us and like have this
notarized
i was so sketched out but i didn't do it
it's just not worth it so i actually
talked to the guy and said listen just
off the record trust me i'm not going to
screw you on this just tell me where it
is i'll claim it my myself and i'll send
you the the money that you do i did yeah
and i claimed the money and i did send
him the money and he said you were the
first person to actually choose 70 what
20 fee i did paid him exactly what he
was out yeah but sure enough it showed
up a few weeks later
and uh yeah i got money he got money i
wouldn't know about it otherwise i
forget what it was for the issue is that
it sounds very sketchy when you're
pitching it to someone you go and you
knock on their door hey you're owed this
amount of money and then you also like
you kind of have to show them but you
don't want to show them because then
they could just fill out the form
themselves obviously if you had that
like automized or automated and you knew
how to like follow the form and
everything and get get it all situated
it it makes it better yeah there are
plenty of people that have like fifteen
thousand dollars on claim twenty
thousand millions there used to be a
news
uh a section in the newspaper and it
said top unclaimed money for our county
uh back in california and it would say
like one million dollars unclaimed by
this person it was fun to look at it's
wobbling yeah
like you know people not taking
advantage of
for example another idea that i had
briefly was a lot of people don't take
advantage of their 401k match at their
employer because they don't they don't
have have the money to contribute to
their 400k 401k and oftentimes the
employer will just match it's like free
money if you contribute to it so some
companies actually emerge that are
lending to employees to say hey we're
going to lend to you put the 401 put in
the 401k get the match and then they
figure out a way to you didn't do that
idea did you no but it is a thing now
yeah so i think three or four years ago
somebody i think it it might have been
asked sebby i think it was assembly like
two three years ago reached out to me to
invest in a startup that was doing just
that
and i couldn't in good conscious um
invest in a company that was tried they
wanted to charge like a 15 percent fee
the fee was so high that was like
yeah they could get money invested but
like if they don't pay that back you
know or they they wanted money in the
back end i forget what it was good
concept but uh
yeah yeah there's just a lot of
opportunities that people aren't taking
advantage of free money for for lots of
reasons sometimes they don't have the
money they need to take advantage of the
free money sometimes they don't have the
time there's companies that will
negotiate your direct tv bill or
whatever and take a percentage of the
savings like on your behalf
uh another idea i had related to that
was a lot of startups actually this was
two or three years ago when interest
rates were much higher um they were
keeping their cash in checking accounts
so you raised 10 million bucks to
startup
and they're just leaving a checking
account where you could you know move it
smartly into the high yield savings and
if you make two percent like
that's 200 grand
that's right right and so like just
free money effectively um
so that was another one there's a lot
now that i'm not probably not thinking
about what's the bad what's a bad idea
that you're just like you looked into it
and you're like
honestly the the whole i don't hate to
burst you guys bubble with the late app
idea i don't know i don't know if it's a
bad idea or poorly executed it's funny
to say that was my favorite idea so far
yeah i think it's just the longest idea
i don't know if it would actually be
something people would use just between
friends it's like who really cares if
someone's probably knows what i don't
like it but like i'm not going to charge
my friend i would feel bad charging my
friend he's late to go get ice cream
with me and i'm like i guess my ice
cream's paid yeah i don't know it's just
like three minutes late i got three
bucks it would be funny if you could
attach a debit card and like venmo you
hold a balance on that and you could
spend their money
attached the yada debit card yeah yeah
perfect can you get tickets it would
work uh perfectly i'll tell you yeah if
you guys prototype that app
i will use it at my wedding because
in the wedding industry people pay
for your plates right they you know
people don't know this but they charge
you you know it could be 150 a plate if
it's really good food and one of my
biggest pet peeves is when people didn't
show up
and so if you guys did build this app i
would implement it in my wedding and i
would charge them their plate price if
they're not there i don't even want to
play pay for it to begin with but
this way if you tell me you're going to
be there you're going to be there
yeah you know what i bet you could
incentivize this because i'm thinking
like imagine like personal trainers
imagine their clients show up late or
something like that and they you know
run
something like that a lot of
professionals a lot of professional
services could do that and use it and
then they get a reward imagine they show
up on time they get like a three percent
discount on whatever restaurants if
someone shows up 20 minutes late it just
screws up the next table the next table
turning to you know can't turn as many
tables yeah i've said this before but
i'll tell you my worst idea you let me
know what you honestly think about this
uh when i was like 20
uh i came up with this idea called truth
and tell
and i bought the domain truthintel.com
and it was basically meant to be a yelp
for people where you could go and you
could make a profile about somebody
write your honest review about them and
we had like a rating system from like
honesty
uh how trustworthy they were personality
you basically there was like five
criteria and then you could write a
review on them you could upload their
picture
did you pursue this at all or it was
just an idea no i pursued it oh wow i
pursued no we so uh it was three of us
me and my buddy jaren and uh my friend
artie
now artie was the one who was the
programmer so he was like yeah and i'll
just work on this on my spare time we're
all kind of we would just get together
once a week it was a fun way to hang out
and we'd just sit there all night and
just make this make this website he
would be you know coding it on the back
and we'd all come up with ideas just
brainstorming but we created truth in
dell.com and uh so what we did is we
started making profiles on all of our
friends
now i have a question yeah what would
you
rate jack oh i
i'd give jack a good rating jack gets a
good rating he gets a good review what
does that mean honestly
like yeah oh yeah yeah oh jack on
honesty at five out of five stars five
out of five wow
yeah wow um but yeah so
now here's the thing we made like 20 30
profiles
and uh
my buddy wrote something on one of our
friends who has a very unique last name
like the type of last name where you
type it in it's like there's no one else
that has his last name but the problem
was that his his dad ran some sort of
construction company with the last name
so it was like the last name
construction inc or like something like
that
so we wrote some well i'm not gonna say
we my friend wrote something about this
person that was just a joke but it was
a rather serious
joke what was the joke yeah i can see
what the joke is oh come on you can't
leave us no i'm not saying which friend
wrote i'm not gonna say i can't say what
the joke was i'm not gonna say i'm
curious what happened i'm not gonna say
so anyway he wrote a very unfunny joke
about this person claiming something
that was not true about this person but
between friends it's like you know you
just kind of ribbit on each other anyway
but anyone can see it anyone can see it
got it the problem was that when you
typed in this construction company our
seo was so good because we had compiled
all this relevant data about like all
these last names that when you typed in
that within like a few weeks that became
the top result on google you just type
in blank construction inc
the sun comes up with this
you know right joke
in his profile
so it hurt
he had first of all a friend had no idea
that we made a profile on him and his
dad had no idea because customers are
calling about it so
we we took that down but uh
we yeah we didn't want to get into any
legal trouble and then then you get into
the
moral issue of like how do you know if
something is correct and there's like
what is it section 230 uh uh i forget
with the the
internet act something section 230 which
basically says that um
if you run a website and somebody writes
something you're not a publisher of that
information and you're not responsible
for what that person says
if you don't edit anything as long as
you as long as you just leave it up on
the website you're not responsible for
it because then you're a public forum
and not a publisher
so if someone says something that's
untrue that like let's say someone loses
their job or something happens
um we couldn't take that down it's just
it's up there
so we never pursued it you're not
allowed to take it down because that
that would be yeah
right interesting exactly so you would
need a way to screen before it even got
there in the first place would that help
or you can't even do that but even then
even even if you screen the the whole
point of this was that it was supposed
to be anonymous but then again it's like
what was the the inspiration like what
was the something in your head that was
like i want this to exist did you have a
really bad experience with someone one
day and you're like man i want to tell
them
i just i thought it would be fun to like
see a review system of like type in a
name and see what other people say about
them did you watch black mirror not show
i don't feel like there was an episode
similar to it oh it was a social score
yeah
so yeah but i'm listen i'm really glad
we never pursued it because uh two other
ladies ended up doing the same thing was
it what was it called the people yeah
yeah yeah yeah i remember and oh my gosh
they were they were on the headline of
everything is like the most hated new
startup like everybody disliked them
they were outed i mean like all this
crazy stuff and we're looking like thank
thank the you know just so thankful we
never pursued that i think someone also
i don't know if this was the same one
you're talking about did it with like
dating dating i think so girls started
guys yeah i think they started with that
maybe they opened it up yeah the help of
people but yes so many issues um
the morality of whether or not you leave
up information that could be hurtful to
another person
um
yeah it's just it's shady
so we never pursued it so what would i
give my rating now on it yeah you could
get you can give
give you a four four out of ten okay
yeah i like the i like the idea
um which would be really tough in
practice right if we could somehow yeah
judge people and have no ahead of time
if they're actually that well or not
maybe it would be helpful the other one
the last one i'll mention is uh that i i
liked a lot you know in los angeles uh
basically all throughout california
parking is really difficult around the
coast you can't find any parking i
wanted to create an app where people
could rent out their driveways i did the
same thing actually in my coding boot
camp it was called park shark mine was
just called the parked
i like park shirts park shark a little
better right
yeah literally we
did that as our project yeah
and it's a thing in the uk
yeah i feel it's called um
park hero or something something like
that yeah we we looked it up there's a
san francisco company that already beat
us to it and they had like a fully
functional beta but it just never took
off and i'm thinking well if this
company tried it and they couldn't do it
and it was gonna be like a hundred grand
to build this thing out it was like i
didn't have the money and the tough part
top part is even building the platform
right it's getting the inventory yes you
gotta get the yeah you can build the
platform
and the other problem is that like the
prime parking spots like if you're in
venice and you have a five million
dollar house you're not gonna care about
renting out your driveway for like ten
dollars an hour and there's a certain
point where it's like beyond that then
it's like you may as well just pay for
valet in l.a so yeah because i had a
similar what started that idea was la
like around the sports stadiums right
there's a lot of parking lots and people
play a lot for parking i was in
wisconsin in august actually you went to
the packers preseason game while i was
there
and i don't know if you ever been to
green bay but around the stadium there's
a lot of small houses and we ended up
parking in a driveway on this woman's
lawn i think she charged 40 or 50 bucks
for the spot
and every game she'd have 20 cars or
whatever profitable yeah and the house
was worth she looked it up like a
million and a half 2 million bucks this
tiny house just because of airbnbs on
on game days wow and for the parking
that was the whole value of the property
so she was just doing it holding up the
sign but yeah i do just want to say
graham did mention this was in like our
second podcast ever we talked about his
bad business ideas
my favorite actually was uh the one
where if you call someone you know how
you hear that
oh yeah i forgot about you you um you
actually hear an ad and then the ad will
lower your phone bill you you're like
yes i i accept to hear ads when i'm
calling somebody what was that about
that idea exactly i thought that was a
great idea i forgot about that yeah um i
i was 18 years old when i came up with
that and i thought you just give people
free phones like just just free cell
phones but every time you make an
outgoing call you have to listen to like
a 15 30 second ad and that would either
give you a free phone or it would lower
your service or you get some something
like that you know um i was like 18 and
like where do i start like how do i even
go about doing this so like when you're
18 no money no connections like i this
idea i wrote it all out
um
just had no idea how to implement that
were you always thinking about ideas too
yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah i would keep a uh uh
just a note on my phone of just like
every time i would think of an idea i'd
write it down
yeah i write down every time i think of
an idea this stupid stuff uh
this morning actually it's in the hotel
and i i can't i'm the only young person
who can't read
and so when i get into these hotel like
showers i can't read which one's the
shampoo and which i need my reading
glasses to read
so i was like oh what if there was and
again the stupidest idea of all time i
was like i need to solve this problem
somehow yeah i write it down i literally
write down
as stupid as that idea i write down on
this list because you never know which
one you know
i mean that one's not going to be the
thing but
just just any like problem i encounter
in society because if you have a problem
so do other people like that's that's
what i've learned is like i used to
think oh
i'm probably only with this problem like
if you have a problem if you're thinking
something there are millions of people
thinking or having the same problem yeah
and if you can solve the problem
you have something yeah so how did yana
bank idea come up so after i tested some
of these other ideas again i built the
prototype for the punctual thing um
and basically again i was always very
interested in finance i was in it and
i've always been super into behavioral
psychology so i don't know if you're
familiar with books like nudge thinking
fast and slow and so when i came across
the statistics about how americans spend
80 billion a year on the lottery
which by the way is the worst gamble you
can make you can go down to the strip in
vegas play blackjack craps people give
you give you crap about it
you're only losing two to five percent
like expected value yeah a lottery
you're losing like 60
people spend 80 billion dollars on that
that's 700 per household the same time
half the country
doesn't have emergency savings
and so a lot of people are playing the
lottery who who struggle to save and so
the idea basically was and i saw this
there's a program in the uk that's
basically what yada is run by the
government
it's putting it a little bit too
simplified yeah yeah
it's huge there and so i saw this
opportunity to do it in the u.s so
ultimately i was like okay why is this
thing so successful in the uk but not
here when we have this problem of
savings and lottery playing
um and it's been successful in lots of
countries so i just started doing
research on it as i always started out
doing um
it turns out it was kind of illegal here
until 2015 it's a relatively new
opportunity
just the ways the way the gambling laws
were written um wasn't like they said
savings with a sweepstakes lottery
element attached to it is illegal it
just would have been a gray area with
gambling
um
because of the way
for for gambling to be gambling there
has to be a prize so there's a prize and
you have to give up consideration to
like participate it's money
yeah so consideration the definition is
it paying for something is it doing
something is it depositing money like is
that consideration
like
i don't know right and so in 2015 they
carved out a law that basically said
this this thing prize-linked savings is
okay
um again more nuance than that why did
they carve out a lot because to do that
there must have been an issue in someone
fighting it who fought that
academics um
so there's a lot of evidence from
programs in south africa new zealand uk
that this actually really helps people
this idea of combining a savings account
with lottery type upside instead of just
boring tiny interest payments helps
people save more money which is good for
society um
generally speaking it's you know you
still need people to spend but
so they changed that expecting that a
business was now going to arise that
would do that possibly yeah so basically
what happened was there was in michigan
i don't know the exact legal details
here but they ran a pilot program in
like 2010 called save to win and by they
i think it was an academically run thing
and they proved over a couple years of
that program that it was also helping
people safe
and so i believe they went to whoever i
don't know the lobby whoever to say hey
this is actually very good for people we
have a savings problem in america
the only downside literally like the
only downside to this is a lot like if
this works and takes off like does it
take away from the lottery
and like most people agree that the
lottery is generally
a tax it's a regressive tax attacks on
on the poor um
and so the problem with the lottery not
only is it horrible it's monopolized by
the government meaning
if if lotteries were privatized meaning
anyone could do it
no company could get away with taking 60
percent cut on on the lottery right
you'd have competition and it would
probably be like blackjack or craps
where it'd be like oh two percent you
lose on average right not 60. wait so
explain the lottery i'm actually not
familiar with this
who who runs it where does that money go
you say it's it's run by the government
states the states the state runs the
how how is the state able to get away
with that do it and does that money go
back into the community is that how they
justify it like hey we're raising this
money
putting it back into the and how much do
you know how much money goes into the
community and how much money people are
making
off top of my head i'm going to get a
little bit wrong but so for every dollar
that goes so first of all 44 states
legalized it i think utah it doesn't
have it some other states if it's like
alaska hawaii something like that some
of them don't have it because for
whatever reason they've said we don't
think this is bad for people or whatever
um i don't know the origins of the
lottery but at some point look people
are spending 80 billion dollars a year
the government's taking i don't know the
exact percentage but it's like
meaningful revenue so anytime the
government's threatened by a revenue
stream like they're going to want to
defend it and the status quo is easier
if the lotteries didn't exist it'd be
hard to say hey let's monopolize a
system where people buy tickets for two
dollars and we're gonna take whatever
people might push back but because it's
been a thing for so long it's harder to
the inertia it's tough to take it away
so for every dollar that goes in the
lottery six percent goes to the
convenience stores that sell it roughly
um
i'm not sure the exact percent that goes
like back to community programs i mean
that's a
big chunk of it sure like that's where
it's going convenience stores prizes and
then prices to the people to buy tickets
and then back to schools or like
whatever but the reality is a lot of
people playing the lottery are the same
people that are like going to these
public schools so you're basically
taking a dollar out of their pocket
paying some convenience stores
and like
redistributing it back to supposedly
those people
probably inefficiently like my view is
the government generally
spends money less efficiently than
individuals who know what they
might want to spend tonight or private
companies i did research on the lottery
oh wow this is probably two years ago so
i wish i wish i had refreshed my uh my
my knowledge of this but i remember
something like um like
it was it was an abnormally high amount
of people who play the lottery are
unemployed
or have a uh uh income significantly
below the poverty line and those make up
like 60 percent of people who play the
lottery very few people earn who earn
above like 70 000 a year play the
lottery i found that was very
interesting
sounds sounds right to me yeah i mean
the thing is you
okay i'm going to spend 10 10 bucks a
week on the lottery okay you're thinking
yourself okay it's not that much like
i'm just having some fun and it's not as
long it's not harmful to you but if you
do over a year that's 500 bucks 30 years
it's 15 grand it maybe you could have
been either saving in the highest
savings account at first and later on
investing and earning seven percent
compounded and that's not 15 000 anymore
it's something much greater at that
investment rate but the psychology is
like what's ten dollars once a week it
feels like nothing yeah and and saving
money
is something that only pays off when you
until it's too late right you had a hot
an injury and you need to pay a hospital
bill
you should have been saving the last
year but you weren't because it wasn't
there's no instant payoff to it
uh the lottery gives you instant payoff
right you have hope you have excitement
for that period of time
people are bad at doing things that are
good for them in the the long run but
have in the short run yeah so i
you know why i was not eating broccoli
all day right like why is everyone going
to the gym
every day all right
once you get sick once you know you
should have been going to the gym then
you start it's like the same type of
type of thing we're not good like
preventative right yeah
i do have to say though part of the fun
for me because i i play the lottery
every now and then and usually when it
gets up to like a crazy amount then i'll
be like you know i'm going to throw like
20 bucks and just see what happens it is
fun
to uh you get that little escape for you
know an hour or so where you think to
yourself what if i win what would i
spend the money agreed everyone does
that you sit there and it's like okay
i'm gonna think about winning here where
is it gonna go and you map it all out in
your head totally and it's totally
healthy it's when you go to a sporting
event you're paying 100 for the ticket
there's no change like you're losing a
hundred dollars you're having
entertainment you're paying 20 bucks for
entertainment and as long as it's
entertainment that's fine but when you
think it's going to get you out of a
poverty trap and that's like your
investment strategy
that's when it's a problem yeah like if
you can afford to lose the money it's
just entertainment right
so you came up with this idea yada bank
to solve this it was legalized 2015. how
do you go about actually starting up a
company like that yeah so the fan the
first step research like is this an
opportunity right once you figure out
you think it's an opportunity now you
have to verify at least that was my
approach so vary one step at a time so
the first thing i did after again
researching looking at other things in
the market seeing like why haven't they
taken off we were not the first um so
you got to figure out why didn't they
take off so we talked to some users of
other apps that existed
tried to figure out what they liked what
didn't they like
next step was try to come up with the
actual concept
put up a landing page so i recommend
anyone do this that's thinking about an
idea very cheap very efficient put up a
landing page that looks legit and have a
wait list and make sure it communicates
like your value proposition of like what
you're going to build maybe even have a
screen with the app that's just designed
right
run ads to it see if are people clicking
through to it
is the value proposition resonating with
them are they willing to sign up for a
waitlist and then we had a survey after
they signed up for the waitlist we
actually spoke to these people about
this product that didn't exist but we
kind of pretended it existed or that we
were working on it like why did you sign
up what what interested you about this
it's really trying to figure out like is
this is there something here it's easy
to sign up for a waitlist so i mean
you know still there's there's degrees
do one percent of people sign up to 15
who visit the page right
even better if you have if you have a
product that people are going to pay for
can you get people to pay in advance for
it or pre-commit like okay once this is
built i will pay 20 per
what a t-shirt like whatever it is yeah
sure because that's more more buy-in um
so we saw some pretty good results with
uh running the ads to that page um why
did the other apps fail yeah so
the biggest one that before us was
called long game
and it was too much of a gamey interface
in my opinion
like
with our product we wanted to make it
very simple and to run in the background
so that could be appealing to a lot of a
wide group of people if you have to log
in every day and spin virtual wheels and
do all these things to win five cents
two cents whatever
at some point
it's not a good return on like your time
like even though it's it's kind of fun
to go in every day and to make five
cents like it's too much effort so we
wanted to make it very simple we wanted
to have a big grand prize they didn't
have their grandfather's like a thousand
dollars
uh we thought having a grand prize was
very very important
because half half the value of the
lottery or pretty much all of it is this
idea you can you can dream big and it's
fun because you have the hope
so if you're only winning 100 bucks 500
bucks is the maximum price
you know it's different right and the
other element was they were very
non-social experiences
so these other apps would um again you'd
spin a virtual wheel you'd do a lot of
these things and it was just you in your
in your own
environment with us we wanted to be
similar to the lottery where everyone
has the same winning numbers right so
midweek you might be talking about it to
each other you're part of the same game
and so i think that makes people talk
about it more which helps with growth
and also it makes it less feel less
rigged it's like playing a slot machine
right sometimes you're like oh i wonder
if it's just rigged against me when
you're spinning a virtual wheel you're
like okay like are they just programming
it to to make me lose
for us
when you have your your phones has the
same numbers as your phones the same as
my phone
it's you know it's not rigged right
so those are some of the reasons okay so
you created this app what was the
feedback like
from the people who signed up on the
waitlist
a lot excited yeah i mean they were like
a lot of them didn't even know high
yield savings accounts were a thing yeah
and so this idea they could get more
than point zero one percent from chase
or wells fargo it was exciting and a lot
of them were like lottery players how
much did it cost to develop the app was
it just you doing all of this on the
back like did you develop the whole
thing or did you like pay out
at that time it was it was just me um
this was literally probably a little
over two years ago
um
first step was not developing it it was
designing it and part of that was also
for the website it was like design the
website and a friend of mine who
actually now works with us
awesome ui ux designer awesome developer
um i just paid him to work with me on
the initial concept hour hourly hourly
payment hourly um so the first step was
designing the concept not getting to
development um
and then i ended up outsourcing the
development to an to a to an agency and
this was still i was paying for this
probably cost 10 to 25 grand early on of
my own money um
and you don't want you don't want to go
straight to development because if
you're going to outsource development
you're going to get something unless
you're very you have it very well
defined you get something you don't
expect
so you want to make sure you have the
everything very specked out when you
click this button this is what happens
this is what the screen looks like don't
leave anything to the imagination
because
again they're they're not incentivized
to build a great product they're
incentivized to get paid by the hour and
so they're going to follow whatever
instructions you give them and they're
probably going to code it
not in the best way but something that
works
so we spent a lot of time writing a
10-page document saying this is how
everything's going to work for the
initial prototype here's what it's going
to look like now i can hand it over to
you to develop
simultaneously we knew this type of idea
was going to require money because we
had to partner with a bank
and banks they spend a lot of time and
investment to working with you and so
they don't want to work with someone who
has no money because are they going to
be around in six months and is it worth
our with our effort so while we were
developing the app i also and the
designs help for this went out put
together an investor deck and raised
from angels friends and family an
initial fundraising round now for this
idea we needed to do that like for some
ideas you can do a lot more
and build it yourself how much did you
have to raise in the beginning and how
do you find a bank to partner with
what's that process like and how much
money do you need like can i go and be
like hey i got like two million bucks
let me let me bank with you if you if
you were serious about it and yeah you
could so wait so you're saying so i
could start my own bank
fund it myself part of my own money
partner with a bank yeah
partner partner
[Music]
so at the time this was two years ago
there's there was
you go directly to a bank in which case
they're not really well-versed in
working with startups and that was they
wanted to have millions of dollars
to work with them
there are a few companies that had
emerged that were in the business of
connecting startups with banks to work
with and these companies because they
were doing it they had the compliance
teams they have everything and their
whole business was connecting banks with
startups they required we still needed
we raised 500 000
so we had to have enough money to where
they wanted to work with us but because
they were kind of this middleman and
they make it a lot easier um that's who
we ended up going with today there are a
lot of these types of companies now
there's probably 10 8 to 10 maybe
companies that their whole business is
to connect banks with startups
there's a lot of regional banks in the
country it's not the chases the wells
fargo of the world that are doing this
because they just doesn't move the
needle for them a lot of regional banks
in tennessee or the midwest
that have consumer branches that there's
not that big and so they realized hey if
we partner with companies that are
raising millions of dollars spending a
lot on advertising and we can
work with them they're they're bringing
us the youth the customers yeah this is
a better strategy
you had to raise 500 000 in order to
be partnered with them
something in that range we ended up
doing 500. the monthly fee itself at the
time was going to be 10 grand a month
and then
we probably could have done a little bit
less but we also need wanted money for
development and other things now were
these banks skeptical like you go to
them and say hey we're running this
prize link savings account kind of it's
running almost as a sweepstakes we don't
want to do that like how many banks were
sketched out and said no yeah there were
when we went directly to the banks
definitely
uh they were like uh
we're not so sure about this like this
sounds a little bit weird
two or three of them probably were like
let's
pass for now yeah two years ago
um
but all you need is one right um and so
but yeah that was an issue uh because it
sounds weird right it sounds weird that
this thing that
totally knew no one's
done a thing like a bank system like
this
um so yeah there were a lot of questions
and a lot of diligence and things like
that to see
like yeah they did diligence for sure
yeah even the ones we partnered with
they did a lot of diligence to make sure
that
what we're doing is kosher yeah so when
you launched then uh what was that
process like how do you how do you even
launch something like that is it just
word of mouth at that point or
so initially again it's just
incrementality right take it steps one
step at a time when we launched we
initially got friends and family to join
mainly because we want to make sure
there weren't any major issues that were
going to be
facing the public when they joined the
app right so probably a few weeks of
just friends and family testing once we
felt good about that the next step we
were
running ads on social trying to get
people to
use the app that weren't connected to us
main reason is you don't want to like
spend a ton of time growing something
that people don't like and so
the first question was can we get 100 or
200 people to sign up make deposits and
like stick around
and until we knew that people were
sticking around it's not it's not worth
investing in growth because if you have
a leaky bucket where people are signing
up sure but they're gonna they're gonna
leave you in two weeks then like what's
the point
so the first step was again can we get
100 200 people to have a good experience
what good experience means can be
different for lots of different
companies for us it was looking at
retention right like
are they depositing two months later are
they growing at the deposits are they
churning are they withdrawing
and then once you get once you feel like
you have something that's retaining
people then i think is the time to just
look at growth
and for us it was still we did a little
bit of paid but not too much the paid
was more the paid ads was more to just
test it out yeah post on a lot of online
forums uh youtube um
things like that and added a referral
program and the fro program's been great
too got it so when i saw ask sebby's
first video reviewing that bank account
had you talked to him before did he do
this on on his own or how how did that
because that that's what caught me we
spoke to him i believe right after the
video so sebby um we were in y
combinator which is a oh yeah tell us
about this so sorry i skipped that part
yeah so what happened there we raised
that 500 000 of funding year and a half
ago now
last summer we and then you so y
combinator is a program in silicon
valley where
you apply to get accepted and they
invest 150 000 at the time uh for a
percentage of the company and you apply
to get in they take one to two percent
of applicants it's pretty competitive
and it's it's almost like the stanford
harvard of like startups you go there um
there's a great group of partners they
call them that have seen everything in
the startup world that give you advice
for a two-month period you're with a lot
of companies in a similar stage all
motivating each other setting goals
learning from each other
so it's almost like a startup school in
a way
so we were in that for two months last
summer
and at the end of it it sets you up very
well
because investors really like to see oh
that company was in y combinator it's a
good stamp of approval of that this is
something possibly worth investing in
obviously you need to show that you are
worth investing in um but sebby i
believe he had kind of followed the y
combinator companies so he saw us and
then reached out i believe right after
the video
and was like hey saw you were in y
combinator seems super interesting would
love to invest
um
sebby is so good so people i i don't
people underestimate it but but i gotta
say he is one of the sharpest
investors when it comes to startup
companies i had no idea i'm asking him
advice on other companies that he's
helping me out with just with these
terms i don't even understand right but
he's able to he's a genius when it comes
to stuff like this right
and so then did he reach out to you
after that i guess i don't even know
yeah so so the story was that uh i kept
getting and i don't know if it was from
sebby's video i kept getting this
comment review yada bank review out of
bank and prior to this i had i was big
on high interest savings accounts so
like every year i'd be like the best
high interest savings account of 2020 or
whatever so people kept saying yada bank
gotta bank out of bank and
i'll be honest i didn't like the name
yada i really didn't get it and i
thought yada is reminds me of that that
old uh early 2000s song where it's like
yeah yeah it just reminded me of that
i'm like yeah like what's the i the name
didn't click with me and it just it
sounded like one of these like gimmicky
things so i i didn't i didn't uh pursue
that
but i happened to see ask sebby's video
that said the best high interest savings
account yada bank i was like okay well
let me at least see this so i watched
this video like that's kind of
interesting so i downloaded the app and
i think
i don't know if i immediately put like
10 grand in the app i put some amount
like that immediately into the app
i think it was 10k and you trusted it
because of ask sebby basically yes only
because of ask yeah if it were anyone
else i i don't i wouldn't have done it
but because i saw his video and then i
read a video from the uh or read a blog
from the doctor of credit
and i think it was between those two
it's like i trust sebby i trust the
doctor of credit if both of these people
are saying well the average interest
rate i think at the time was like two
and a half percent something like that
i'm like let me try it out and so i put
ten thousand dollars in the app and i
think it was like that first week and
this is a fluke of luck by the way i had
won like 200 and something dollars like
300 bucks that first week
and again that was a fluke so i text
asked sebby my winning numbers and i
said like hey by the way i just want to
say thank you for your video
because of your video uh i won like 300
bucks this is so cool and i remember
telling jack about this too and macy
because if i referred
i think it was for every referral i got
like 100 tickets or something like that
so i was like well if i could get an
extra 200 tickets today just by telling
jack and macy i'm gonna do it so then
they both signed up i got my extra
tickets and i was like i'm all stoked
about this i was planning to make a
video about it and so then he introduced
me to you
after i told him that i was really
impressed i was planning to make a video
anyway reviewing it but then being in
touch with you was like i wanted to be a
part of it yeah we had a mutual mutual
friend too from l.a yeah so what what
was the high school you went it was like
harvard west lake well which high school
were you uh new roads yeah okay yeah and
what year i was two class of 2008 2010
okay yeah yeah but still all those
groups kind of overlap a little bit but
yeah we had a mutual friend yeah um i
don't remember who i think spencer
friedman yeah yeah spencer and i think
spencer was also in investment banking
yeah can you go into that yeah
okay so there we go exactly yeah so he
dated my girlfriend at the time her one
of her best friends oh yeah interesting
yeah everything everything comes
together yeah so anyway so just with all
these connections i felt comfortable and
i was like i want to invest i want to
find some way where i could get involved
in this uh because i'd never done an
investment like that before like my
investments were always really up until
that point was just like real estate
roth ira that was it so for me this was
like a brand new world and uh ask sepi
was really helpful navigating a lot of
that and answering those questions so
then i made my video
and tell us what happened because uh i
don't know if you were prepared for as
many people to sign up yeah that was
quite quite a weekend uh i think it went
out on a friday night
um and we just had sign ups coming in
left and right and up and down and
uh all weekend we didn't have a customer
support team yet so like we had i was
helping on the customer support and all
weekend we were just trying to trying to
keep things up uh so yeah it was
that was a crazy weekend i think we we
tripled like that weekend you know in
terms of sign ups yeah um
but along with that though we got to
talk about the the ponzi scheme oh yes
what is this what is this
i gotta say a lot of people were very
upset because they said i can't believe
graham is going to promote a ponzi
scheme this sounds like a ponzi scheme
this is like this is gambling
uh i want you to address everyone who
says it's a ponzi scheme
why it's not a ponzi scheme how we
actually know the numbers being picked
are truly double-blind how do we know
that nobody knows the numbers before how
do we know that you're not involved in
this or like
explain the background about this so
i'll start with maybe the gambling side
so what makes
it what makes gambling gambling is the
possible loss of money with us you
deposit money it's an fdic insured bank
you cannot you can never lose that uh up
to 250 000 that's just the law the same
way chase bank of america operate
so gambling means you can lose money in
terms of the prize drawings we have a 10
million dollar jackpot which if someone
won that prize us paying it out would be
pretty harmful to the business obviously
we partner with an insurance company
that we pay them for every entry no
matter what every week a certain amount
of money and if someone hits the jackpot
they pay it out
and because of that every week they pick
the winning numbers and there's no way i
guess for me to prove this to you but
they pick the winning numbers they don't
see anyone's picks we in theory could
see the picks like we don't but
obviously it's our app like we could see
what the numbers are
you're saying you could see the numbers
before they come out no we could see
like you pick one two three four five oh
so you can see my numbers that i picked
but you couldn't see their numbers that
they so if we were the ones p we're
picking the winning numbers every night
like you could say oh yeah adam are you
guys looking at graham's picks and
saying okay i'm going to pick numbers
nobody has right
but because the insurance company is
picking it
it's it's blind they don't see they have
no way to see the numbers people are
picking we have no way to know what
numbers they're choosing
um how do i prove this to you 100
percent i mean i i don't know you could
contact the company and do some do some
diligence on it that is how it works
um and the reality is we want someone to
win if anything we want someone win the
grand prize we're paying for we're
paying the insurance anyway
so if someone wins that prize that would
be amazing no publicity is it like car
insurance are you getting an accident
like your insurance goes up and somebody
hits 10 mil
insurance go up after that no because
the reality is why does insurance again
why does insurance go up after an
accident something has changed about you
as a driver you're now riskier because
you're underwriting something that is
not certain there's different decisions
between risk and uncertainty
with a sweepstake system with numbers
being drawn you can calculate the exact
math behind the game
so just because someone wins doesn't
change the underlying principle of this
is the math whereas if you're doing
home and home insurance right and it's
louisiana there's a hurricane or
whatever
maybe something changes in your model
where you're like okay we underestimated
the actual risk because there is no math
behind it it's just history
right right and so with car insurance it
goes up probably because they're like
well
they gave him insurance last time
because he had a clean driving history
he's gotten an accident maybe he's not
as safe as we thought with this someone
who wins they're like okay math changes
sure right yeah now you do say that uh
you don't lose anything one of the
comments that i got repeatedly is that
technically you are gambling with the
extra money that you could have made at
ally bank so you're paying a point two
percent interest rate alibank is paying
point five so you're paying point three
percent interest on your money for the
chance it at earning way more than that
that is there is an opportunity cost
right so let's say you get really lucky
with us you might get a ten percent apy
you get super unlucky lucky win no
prizes you might get the base 0.2
percent so yes when you win less than
what ally is paying guaranteed you might
have lost some foregone opportunity cost
that that that's real i mean but you're
still not
losing anything in the sense of what you
put in like yes there might be an
opportunity cost there the reality is
with our prizes the average uh people
win a lot more than point five percent
on average
but if you if you win less than that
sure you could have made more the same
way when you're sitting on the couch on
a friday night watching tv you could be
driving an uber and you could have made
ten dollar like yeah sure there's that
element but
but you can't yeah
whatever you put in is totally totally
protected whenever you win is protected
but if you view it from an opportunity
cost perspective yeah sure but so is
that everything in life right you know
maybe i could have
done something you know yeah so
that's what i would say does the
insurance company pay out every single
payout or do they just pay out the price
just the grand prize got it the rest of
the prizes are funded from for miata um
yeah got it so it's only the 10 million
yep got it okay and yeah again the
reason we we did this is because again
we thought having a big jackpot was very
important there's a chicken and egg
problem which is you can't offer a big
jackpot unless you have a ton of people
you can't have a ton of people unless
you've grown and so if you want to offer
a big prize from day one you need to do
it you need to do it with insurance yeah
if you go to a sporting event there's
the half court shot a lot of these
prizes are really insured
um
so a lot of these jackpots you see in
the world not the lottery because again
the lottery is millions of participants
every week they don't need it but
that's interesting really curious can
you say how much that insurance costs
um asking important questions
is it paid like per month
it's paid per entry so every ticket has
a cost associated with it no way
yeah i did not it makes sense the more
entries and more chances to win
so
um so yeah every month it costs us
around the tens of thousands uh for the
insurance on that jackpot wow um yeah
and so how they price it how they think
about it is what are the odds of someone
winning what is our payout and like any
insurance how much we need to charge to
make a margin on that yeah um
is there a certain time or amount that
you guys will have to be worth until you
guys remove the insurance yes uh we have
to get uh there's a much bigger to be
able to do 10 million on like a weekly
basis
we'd probably start out by doing it
on a monthly basis or something like
that first but again when you're funding
a jackpot like that with the lottery
every dollar that goes in is a dollar
that contributes to the
to the pool with us it's a percentage of
that right and so
it requires way more scale so in the uk
for example they offer two prizes of a
million a month not a week um and they
have
a third of the population on it and so
you need massive scale before you can
like self-fund
the huge prizes this is expensive to run
how expensive is it every month like are
what are the overhead costs how many
employees are involved do you pay
yourself a salary yep so it's in the
hundreds if that i don't get the exact
numbers it's in the hundreds of
thousands per month uh to operate
um
12 full-time employees and then we work
with a bunch of freelancers and agencies
that probably makes us in the 20s
um
and yeah we pay everyone everyone makes
salary so i mean my co-founder and make
a salary
um
can you save what you're selling no i
can't i can't i can't
maybe one day if i have a big youtube
channel and you know then i'll then i'll
publish all the financial details
but not today
okay i want to know that's fine
we want to know
not today okay it's in line with what
you'd see at any series a funded like
startup we have
we have a lot of metrics and and
intelligence on
there's a lot of data out there on what
people in any role at a startup make and
we use that when same thing without me
my co-founder so got it it's you know
median for for
yeah our type of company got it uh what
sort of expenses have come up that you
have not anticipated uh fraud
so yeah you can plan for all your
expenses but you don't know how much
first of all you know how much fraud was
that big of a deal and you know how much
it's going to be in a given month
because sometimes you have like fraud
rings that try to do crazy stuff
um i don't want to get into details of
how they they get away with it but the
banking system is
the rules around the bank system are
written such that it's very easy to
commit financial wire ach fraud removing
money
so every month like
you know we're doing a better job of
this and a lot of people will complain
oh why are my limits this why is it this
and i'm not trying to commit fraud and
like yeah but there's the there's the
sub 1 of people that are and it kind of
ruins
it's why settlement times have to be a
little bit longer it's why limits have
to be a thing
and it sucks because it ruins it for all
the people that are good actors but
um that's been the one that and that can
be in the tens of thousands a month like
um
easy
and it's a big problem across the whole
industry right now with covet
now about the sweepstakes aspect of this
technically to be a sweepstakes you have
to have a no consideration entry which
means you can mail in an entry
uh how many millions do you get
we don't get very many uh in the you do
get something we get some okay single
double digits
type range yeah so nothing that really
moves the needle the reality is
the postage costs like for it's you know
it's just not worth it for people yeah i
mean some people don't do the math but
it costs 50 cents to mail something i
mean most people on the app have a lot
of tickets right so they're winning
stuff but even one ticket yeah you're
probably not going to win the 50 cents
back in a given week yeah and so
yeah you know what's wild so i i don't
want to say i learned this the hard way
but uh i wanted to do a giveaway with
public.com link down below in the
description you can get a free stock
worth all the way up 2 000 so i wanted
to do that but i wanted to i was i
thought it was such an easy thing i was
like how about this i'm gonna pay out of
pocket to give somebody a free stock who
just goes on public deposits 100 bucks
and uh in the next week i just want to
get just
i'm paying out of pocket on like i'm
doing this myself just want to give them
a free share of tesla a 700 share and
just randomly pick somebody for one
winner for one one winner
i did not realize the legal complexity
of doing that and all of a sudden now
that's considered gambling
even though technically you don't have
to invest the hundred you could deposit
a hundred and then take it out
immediately after
uh technically that's gambling because
now you're paying paying right uh for
the chance to win a prize
oh my gosh the legal work that we had to
do
unfortunately it kind of ruined it but
um
yeah that goes back to the initial point
about consideration right right so
depositing money is could be
consideration it was horrible so it was
like a few weeks of and
public has an amazing legal team that
like worked with me to try to get this
done
uh but yeah part of that was that you
there there's a mail in entry
and i'm thinking okay it's it's it's in
a disclaimer it's in the fine print and
you like you have to scroll down to like
see no purchase necessary
click the link uh you know you figure
out where to mail your entry
um so i was thinking what maybe like a
few people are going to do this hundreds
wow i kid you not a po box for them for
the mail hundreds uh yeah well no well i
don't handle it yeah so they handle it
all right so like i'm removed i'm simply
just like funding this but they're
they're legal it probably cost them way
more to give away this stock to comply
with regulation but um the founder of
public sent me a picture with this these
bins of envelopes that were all entries
and i'm like how and it turns out what's
interesting is that there are these
sweepstake groups
that what they do is they automatically
compile and it's group of like they're
almost always like you know i don't want
to say the elderly but they're almost
always people uh in their 60s and 70s uh
who they get in these groups sweep saves
groups and they all do it together and
they have a big list and they don't even
know what they're signing up for they're
just like the mail mail mail right and
it's just a numbers game and they
eventually get it back do they do they
automate the printing of the entries you
know or they hand write it uh because
you can you can usually say it has to be
handwritten yeah on the picture and alex
you know what i could maybe send you
this um maybe i could send you a picture
yeah here's okay so here's one of the
bins
how wild is that look at that
one that's one of the bins look
those are all entries there are a lot of
those those are all answers yes multiple
multiple bins and this was this was a
disclaimer on the bottom of your page on
the website so they they
had to comply with whatever the
regulation was so whatever was required
to make it a legal sweepstakes oh yeah
that's what they did totally no yeah but
i know for myself like you don't look at
the no purchase necessary option in the
fine print and see like there's probably
some forum or something that can go and
they can find all of the people running
sweepstakes and they'll load it onto
there yeah and it's is it worth it right
so so when you're giving away a thousand
dollar prize i could see that for sure
like or 700 tesla stock
someone's just like oh let me take a
shot at 700. with us it's a little bit
like oh what's a ticket what's it worth
it's a little bit less um
you know clear yeah and so yeah one is
if you offer a sweepstakes that is too
valuable
yeah that is interesting you could have
said okay uh if you sign up you get 100
tickets uh and then if you do the
mail-in or entries and if you do the
mailing you get one ticket
you might be able to do something like
that there are some nuances where you
have to give mail-ins the same like
so they could be able to mail 100 times
yeah you could do that if they'd if
they'd have to be able to mail in 100
times to get 100 entries to be able to
do the same if you get a million tickets
yeah
yeah so
yeah it's uh
it's unfortunate because a lot of these
giveaways
the mailing entries make the sweepstakes
almost like not possible sometimes but a
lot of these sweepstakes are they're not
again i don't think they're gambling
right like it's
it's just the way the laws are written
unfortunately right you're not trying to
there's nothing
negative that could happen to anyone if
you don't have the mailing option right
right when are you planning on like
dissolving your relationship with evolve
bank like what evaluation do you guys
have you need to have to have your own
bank and then also at what point are you
guys just going to sell it off or are
you going to continue to grow up forever
yeah so on the evolve side um no plans
to switch anytime soon or to focus on
that um
there's a lot of big neo like even the
biggest neobanks out there generally are
still partnering with banks
you need to get to a scale that like it
really makes sense to go through the
effort of sometimes you buy a bank or
you become you actually buy a bank to
get their charter or you become a bank
and go through the chartering process
it's very expensive very time consuming
and so when you're a young company
you're really trying to prove out like
is there a demand for this product your
risk isn't like we we know we can cut
costs like we know we can be more
efficient we know that the question is
can we attract enough attention enough
users enough deposits enough
product use at which it makes sense to
start cutting those costs because we
again we have fixed resources we need to
focus on that right now because we know
the other stuff is possible just takes
time and money and so
you know switching banks is always a
possibility
um because again you have terms with the
banks in terms of what is an ach cost
what there's fees all over the board
there that we pay the bank to work with
them so if we can switch to a bank
that's giving us a better deal that's
always a possibility for us there is a
lot of headache to doing that if you
look at your debit card it'll say the
bank's name on it so we have we'd have
to manage multiple programs where we
have to have some evolve and some new
bank
so it's it's a bit of a headache for
sure
in terms of like selling or growing
we're very focused on just growing as a
standalone
uh entity right now
what would that look like in a few years
from now like where do you see yada
integrating and
because it's got to be more than
just a savings account right now yeah
and so far we've rolled out a lot of new
new features that make it more than a
savings account uh debit card there's
now more flexibility in terms of bill
pay sending checks depositing checks you
can really use it as a full bank right
now and we're working on credit cards
credit building loan products tell
people build their credit um someday we
want to get into like the etf investing
right helping people because once you
save the next step is to start investing
we don't want to be like a robin hood
offering individual stocks and make it
like that we want to probably do more
index fund type stuff so the next two
years we want to become a place people
can really make it their primary bank
and so we're doing a lot of stuff
related to that um also very focused on
adding a lot of social features
um that help people enjoy it together
which improves our defensibility so if
someone copies us it's harder to leave
if you and your friends are all
participating what is the typical let's
say for myself as an investor what's the
typical return look like down the line
is it usually an acquisition we
sell
or is it it just gets so big that it's
profitable and profits are shared or is
it like it becomes a publicly traded
company or how does that it work so it's
probably more common so most startups
fail right and so it's more common that
failing sometimes means you get higher
you get aqua hired you get
bought out for a very small amount and
investors get their money back or
percentage of it sometimes if they lose
they get some of it back
so that's probably by far the most
common on a
number of times it happens basis on like
a dollar's return basis to investors i
would imagine that companies that are
standalone companies in ipo make up a
lot of the dollar
right percentage of returns to investors
um so the big ipos and then
you know the biggest ipos are usually
bigger than the biggest acquisitions
which is why
um so yeah at some point it's not that
you share
i mean you could share in the profits if
if the company pays out dividends at
some point that's usually way down the
line especially for a tech startup
yeah so it seems like either the options
are ipo at the top acquisition
and then
what then the company just doesn't just
fails and now now let's say for both for
myself and for a user of yada bank let's
just say
doesn't work out
i'm guessing there's never a point where
there's not a value to the company so
there's always something
that could be like hey well we fail but
this company's willing to buy us out at
x amount take over all of our users and
then yeah yeah we saw that happen
recently with i think uh simple bank or
something where they were kind of like
uh i don't know the exact details but
like picking pnc bought them or aqua
hired them and they just rolled they
rolled simple into their into their
existing product and they just renamed
it so i mean if that happens yeah
sometimes they'll a company could take
you over and keep you operating as a
standalone app sometimes they'll
integrate you into their existing
product and so you'll just roll your
accounts into their existing
um application whether for pnc pnc like
whatever
um
so yeah that's that's how it would
probably play out in that case what
would be your goal let's say five years
from now
five years from now i mean
i guess ipo is the ultimate goal like
standalone company um
why and why would there be an ipo is
that is a way to cash out or is that as
a way to like the next way to grow or
because it seems like if you get to a
point of an ipo
uh
why do that
for the company yeah unless it's to
raise more capital so
in the current world like you can be a
private company right now and raise a
lot of money there's like a lot of money
20 years ago people weren't raising
billions of dollars in the private
markets i don't think and so people
would use the ipo to be able to raise a
lot more in today's world it's probably
more common to ipo not for the money
because you can usually get the money in
private markets but for a lot of
investors employees
founders us
um you know they've been they've been
had their cash locked up for a long time
and it's it's it's a way to cash out for
sure
uh usually it's not about and that's why
you're seeing a lot of direct listings
do now from tech companies direct
listings mean you ipo but you're not
selling new shares you're not raising
money for the company you're just
listing and existing shares are bought
and sold um
so yeah a lot of people will say it's to
raise money i i think it's usually to to
get liquidity for it's not for the
investors and for the founders and
employees that have been locked up with
with the shares and for a long time
now what would it take in anybody ipo or
just does it have to be built out to a
certain amount before you decide to do
an ipo how does that so i'm not sure if
there's like a threshold there probably
is a threshold in terms of what your
implied valuation would be there's
public companies that are in the low
hundreds of millions valuation pretty
rare to be under like 100 million in a
public company unless you started out
way bigger and you've just share prices
gone down
[Music]
the typical ipo is probably in the
i don't know 500 million to 10 billion
valuation range okay uh there probably
is some thresholds around i don't think
it's a revenue threshold i think it's a
number of shares and evaluation but i
don't know
there's something and what would yata
have to do to get to that point
i i don't know off hand i mean
i don't know okay we'd have to be yeah
we'd have to millions millions of users
um
yeah really i'd say millions of users is
probably the the bar okay um yeah
got it you could make us one step closer
using the link down below in the
description
nice yeah yeah 100 tickets do you refer
wait wait who's who's link graham
i want my i want 100 tickets you want
that but i want hundred tickets too
we'll work it out there's one thing that
i feel like um
with the debit card i told you about the
the venmo cash app situation with it
very interesting so people are venmoing
people
they're you know the friends all the
time you're not getting any rewards for
it
correct you get charged a fee for using
a credit card on venmo cash app all
these services because
merchants pay a fee if you use a debit
card on all these platforms they don't
charge a fee
but no one does this because most debit
cards don't have rewards so what's
really interesting is with our debit
card you get tickets plus you get the
chance to get what you just bought for
free
you use it on on venmo cash app a lot of
these like peer-to-peer payments uh
platforms you get those rewards so right
now let's say you send jack 20 bucks for
for dinner right now you're you're doing
on venmo and you're not getting rewards
you use a debit card you get whatever
worth debit card has because they
process it as a purchase which is a very
interesting like use case we've seen
in general what's the limit on that it's
whatever the so they it's a purchase
right so the venmo is processing it as a
purchase so it's whatever limits they
have
for you and that could be different
now
what's to stop me from then mowing jack
to venmo me jack and just bounces
between us
that was a good catch
did we get we got that
we got that
play it back in slow mo please
obviously we hit a uh sensitive
was wow okay
wow what's the stop so nothing
nothing says stop it except venmo's
policies or cash house policies it's
just processes of purchase does that
hurt yatta no at all no no it's uh where
does the money come from though because
here's the the thing is that if we keep
bouncing money back and forth we're
racking up tickets between us yes uh who
pays there's there's a little
interchange fee yes who pays that so
interchange for those who don't know
credit cards and debit cards when you
buy a sandwich the merchant is paying
the card networks the issuing bank of
the card a fee
for their servicing of that payment they
do it because
people are used to paying with cards now
sometimes people pay more than the in
the history they paid more with cards
and with cash and so it's just people
spend more because they feel like it's
plastic and not real money but these
merchants pay a fee with credit cards
that fees often like two to three
percent with debit cards it's typically
like five to ten point zero five to
point two percent so it's very cheap
so when you're making a bigger purchase
often or you're using venmo or whatever
they're not gonna let you pay with send
money to jack with a credit card because
they're paying three percent with most
debit cards they're paying a tiny fee
and they do it because it's convenience
they want to have money move easily and
so they don't charge fees for debit
cards
there was an amendment passed in 2010
2011 small banks
small issuing banks that have debit
cards get paid a lot more interchange so
whereas traditional bank of america
debit card makes
point one percent on every transaction
smaller banks to make one to one point
six percent
and so you're able to give better
rewards as a smaller or if you partner
with a smaller bank or if you are a
smaller bank but a lot of companies
don't charge fees for debit cards
because 99 of the debit card
transactions are from big banks and it's
like zero
and so it's just an interesting
that's really interesting and they just
passed that because they wanted more
small banks i don't know the reason why
they passed i i don't know
there's got to be a reason i i've not
looked in like the reason why that was
passed that's fascinating
so you just pass on the rewards to us so
yeah when you're venmo someone venmo's
paying an interchange fee when anyone
use a debit card they're paying a fee
um
and so yeah we've seen people use it for
for venmo for rent or you know sometimes
you pay your rent and you're paying a
you can't use a credit card but they
often accept debit card
that's maybe you guys can start just
bouncing money back and forth venmo
might uh have problems with it
but how much i i cause i then mode quite
a lot of money back and forth just
throughout you know whatever
um it i wonder how high the amount would
have to be for them to catch on and
let's have a limit
yeah
it's like a thousand dollars or what is
it again it's probably they probably
have a different limit for different
people that's the thing they probably
have different limits alex
alex pull that up
while we're waiting on that um i wanted
to ask you this too do you have any
concerns over the regulation of
gamification
uh for those that don't know rob
robinson is under fire because they've
gamified investors they made it really
fun like you scratch off a ticket and
confetti comes down you make a trade
it's like oh you made your first trade
they make it like a video game are you
concerned that yada is similar to that
aspect where it's like a number rolls
out of a rolling thing and you know is
that a concern the concern is more that
like perception can be reality but if
you really look at it like
gamification itself is not the bad thing
right the reason robin hood gets
scrutiny is because they gamify
something that makes people do do a
risky thing that sometimes they don't
know what they're doing
it's not gamification that's bad right
it's the fact that it's driving a
behavior that people don't understand
they think their stock's always gonna go
up so they put too much money in it and
it can go can go down
so i don't think gamification is bad but
i think public perception is often oh
this thing looks like this thing so this
is bad and you know this is bad because
this is bad or possibly bad it's a
perception perspective yes we have to
educate people yes it's gamification
like a robin hood but the key difference
is
again all the money's fdic insured you
could say you're losing an opportunity
cost of foregoing a return in the market
or in an ally or whatever it is
um
but like gamification itself in my
opinion like the way we're using it is
not
it's not a negative right got it alex we
find those limits yes uh it is 4999.99
per week
uh as long as you have a
you know id link to your account which
is got it we all do it and that makes
sense i don't think i have an idea yes
all right your limit is 299
and 99 cents per week the what is
300 if you have no like uh ideally
yeah yeah
i was looking online on youtube and i
saw that somebody
actually won the tesla and maybe you
guys according to your calculations you
didn't expect them to win so fast is
that true
so i actually think
we've had fewer tesla winners than
expected so far which is just a matter
of luck right it's it's a sample size so
no we actually expected someone to win
like it's not that it's not that crazy
that someone won it um
so yeah no i think it wasn't that crazy
given given the math behind it
did they take the tesla tesla or the
cash equivalent tesla every single time
uh only one winner so far oh oh
yeah i've seen his uh you reached out to
him and you made a video with him right
yeah it's good advertising yeah exactly
yeah that's great i want to ask a
question that i want to know but the
audience might want to know and i don't
know if you can answer it graham all
right let's hear it how much did you
invest in yada yada can't save
wait you can't say because you don't
want to or you actually can't say it's
in it's it's it's six figures it's in
the six figures wait what
yeah
it is yeah
i don't remember that yeah really oh
but if you wanted to say could you say
it
uh i don't know i don't know yes
i don't know
i'd rather you i'll say no it's better
it's better leave it to the imagination
oh thank you i'll say i'll say you can't
yeah okay
good question though good question
because that's in the tough world they
were probably wondering yeah you know
the audience yeah yeah definitely leave
it to the imagination thank you so much
it was really nice meeting you too thank
you nice meeting you guys uh finally i
know i know thank you so much for making
it all the way up to vegas for doing
this means a lot thanks for having me
yeah sure i don't want to make this come
off as like sounding uh sponsored or
anything like that because it's not um
but we uh
we were able to work out just now if you
do actually want to sign up we'll give
you an extra 100 tickets on top of your
extra 100 tickets we'll find a link down
below in the description so if you want
to sign up try it out and uh if you have
any uh issues or anything now you could
reach out to the
customer service do you ever answer
those yeah
people reach out to me all the time too
adam at withyatta.com oh you just you
don't know what you just did yeah well
we'll see we'll see
i'll uh hopefully respond to most you
guys oh geez
thank you so much
you can guess my email anyway right like
you know once i invited it but yeah you
know what's surprising uh a lot of the
emails that like the top companies are
the most simple things it's like either
first or last name at thecompany.com
and uh
it's so easy and and these people check
their emails it's it's mind-blowing how
easy it could be to correctly guess it
i've heard stories of elon musk types
like responding to elon musk but people
were in response berkshire hathaway dot
com yeah
yeah so
mr b
[Laughter]
bh yeah anyway thank you guys so much
for watching make sure to subscribe
check out the clips channel down below
in the description hit the like button
that helps us out oh you know what you
actually have to tell them look at the
camera say destroy the like button for
the youtube algorithm destroy the like
button for the youtube algorithm i've
always wanted to say that thank you
thank you so much i appreciate it thank
you thank you until next time awesome oh
thank you man you gotta take us can we
take a selfie in here yeah
you gotta get the crew